[Musique]
le quartier de la Sourderie à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux le prisme à
Élancourt encore le boulevard Vauban à
Guyancourt le photographe François
Bellefontaine aime se balader dans les
centres-villes de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et capturer
des moments de vie grâce à son appareil
photo de ville
ce qu'on appelle la street photo aussi
dans le langage courant après pour faire
de la photo de ville c'est souvent New
York c'est Paris mais bon c'est c'est
déjà fait je dirais et je pense qu'on
peut faire en fait c'est un moyen de
prouver qu'on peut faire de la photo de
rue à proximité de chez soi j'habite à
Montigny voilà entre guillemets la ville
nouvelle donne l'opportunité d'avoir des
architectures qui permettent de faire
cette photo de rue que j'apprécie
[Musique]
avec une préférence pour la photographie
en noir et blanc François Bellefontaine
s'intéresse aux lignes au contraste et à
la lumière elle se compose de plusieurs
plans donc on a vraiment là il y a pas
de retouches c'est une photo au prix en
une fois donc on arrive à la fois avoir
des transparents des reflets des lignes
géométriques donc ça ça fonctionne bien
avec le noir et blanc on a un bâtiment
sur la place d'Espagne qui est assez
particulier assez emblématique voilà je
voulais aussi essayer d'avoir du
mouvement avec une technique de de
comment de zooming pour essayer d'avoir
un effet de voilà et toujours une
silhouette quelque part les arbres
donc et puis toujours un petit côté
mystérieux aussi
[Musique]
l'exposition des lumières et des Ombres
est disponible jusqu'au 27 mars à la
bibliothèque de l'université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin pour les
intéresser François Bellefontaine
organisent des stages de photographie
les vendredis 10 et 17 mars pour
participer il est nécessaire de
s'inscrire sur le site internet de la BU
de l'UVSQ